groups of students across America say
they will skip class tomorrow for the
first national school strike over
climate change we've already seen
similar demonstrations in Europe and
Australia
tomorrow's protests are planned in more
than 130 US cities and about 90
countries worldwide Tony to cope will
talk with organizers about the goal of
the walkout and he joins us at the table
to discuss good morning good morning
we've seen student Walcott's for gun
control now it seems climate change is
getting the same treatment and this is
expected to be a major protest but it
began with just a few teenagers on
social media they were reading about the
worst-case scenarios of climate change
and they came to a pretty logical
conclusion why keep going to school to
prepare for a future that might not even
exist
[Music]
every Friday as most kids hurry off to
school
Alexandre Villa Senior heads to the
United Nations
she's climate change will be a global
problem I decided that this would be the
best place to strike the seventh grader
plays hooky in hopes of pushing adults
into action against global warming what
did your mom say when you proposed the
idea of not going to school on Fridays
well both of my parents were very
supportive they I mean they understand
my point of view no double-take at all
well they did start laughs crying but I
took that that's a good sign she's been
doing it for more than three months but
it won't be a one-girl show come
tomorrow all 50 states are going to be
striking that day he supported all the
strikers Villa signore is co-founder of
youth climate strike us along with 12
year old Haven Coleman and 16 year old
Ezra her see they're calling for among
other things 100 percent renewable
energy by 2030 and the three young women
were inspired by a fourth with not doing
anything to fight the climate crisis
Greta tun brewery started her own
Fridays for the Future strike last
August
outside the swedish parliament in
stockholm change is coming whether you
like it or not since then she's taken
her message directly to the United
Nations Climate Change Conference known
as cop 24 you are not mature enough to
tell it like it is even that burden you
leave to us killed
I was amazed because she put the world
leaders in their place
she really pointed out that they are
acting like children I'll link you into
all the emails Kay Haven Coleman is
organizing students from her home in
Colorado it doesn't matter if we get
thousands it doesn't matter if we get
hundreds we're still influencing we're
still powerful because a voice is a
voice and every voice has power a lesson
you don't always learn in a book in a
fight that certainly won't be over
tomorrow if you could teach everybody
one thing about what you've learned
about climate change what would it be
that a lot of world leaders and
politicians have to start making
decisions based on facts they need to
start listening to scientists and they
need to stop being bought off and if
they don't if they don't then you can
say goodbye to your life and your future
we will continue striking until the
necessary actions are taken we will not
be stopping and while you can argue with
the tactics scientists have provided a
pretty good sick note for the planet in
the form of the latest international
report on climate change when we're
studying history they're gonna try to
make it right do we point out that most
of those leaders in that package were
young girls in fact not only here in the
US but around the globe most of the
leaders in this movement are women young
women yeah I like that I like her thing
about laughs crying yeah no there's
nothing to do with this story you know
Tony Duke opal is a good guy anybody who
comes to work wearing his wife's socks
better teal they're colorful I picked
them out in the dark I don't want to
wake her they're on my feet now it's a
real man this is what you learned when
you go into the green room on your feet
there Tony your socks into you